Welcome to the deep dive.
This is where we take your
curiosity, combine it with our
research, sift through some
really fascinating sources, and
well, try to distill the most
potent insights we can just for
you.
Today we're doing a deep dive
into a pretty insightful
analysis by Chris Abraham.
It's called WAG, the Vanguard
Spectacle, Power and the Death
of the one who asks for Credit.
OK, so our mission today really
is to try and unravel this core
paradox.
Why do the grandest visions for
the future, you know, the big
plans, so often seem to fall
apart, while at the same time
the most profound changes, the
ones that really stick, often
unfold almost invisibly?
We're going to explore that,
that intriguing tension between
the designers and the people
actually living within those
designs, and hopefully uncover
some surprising truths about how
really impact happens in the
world.
Maybe a few aha moments along
the way.
Yeah.
And what's particularly striking
in Abraham's piece is how he
uses these really vivid
analogies, you know, from that
psychological parable with the
marshmallows, the marshmallow
test, exactly, all the way to
the quiet resilience of, like, a
local grocery store.
We'll try to connect these
illustrations to the bigger
picture, the dynamics of social
reform, political strategy, and
hopefully encourage you to
question some common assumptions
about power and influence.
And we'll really think about
where true agency actually lies.
So Abraham kicks things off by
highlighting what he calls a
structural tension in modern
cultural discourse.
It's this fundamental, often
unseen tug of war.
On one side, you've got the
conceptual vanguard.
Think of them as the architects
of ideas, right?
The system builders.
The theorists.
The ones publicly pushing for
these grand, sometimes utopian
possibility.
And then on the other side, you
find the people whose lives are,
well, supposed to inhabit these
structures that have been so
meticulously designed.
The author notes they often get
simplistically labeled the
masses, but he sees them as less
abstract, more kinetic and,
crucially, far more resistant to
just being shaped or molded.
This isn't exactly a new
dynamic, is it?
It's a pattern we've seen play
out again and again from
intellectual salons to, you
know, academic institutions
throughout history.
Definitely.
And this is where what he calls
the friction of handoff really
comes into play.
Every idealistic project,
doesn't matter how perfectly
it's conceived on paper,
eventually hits this this
critical moment.
It's like going from that clean
architectural sketch to the
messy reality of a construction
site.
The vision is born in these
rooms, maybe with whiteboards
and specialized jargon, and then
it gets delivered to a reality
that frankly didn't ask for it
and doesn't necessarily play by
its rules.
And the implication there is
about what gets lost in that
handoff.
Abraham argued that something
invariably gets lost, or maybe
burned or just casually
discarded.
It's not necessarily presented
as a moral failing on anyone's
part.
He frames it almost like like a
function of thermodynamics.
You know, heat escapes precision
and blurs.
And the people the structure was
supposedly built for start using
it in ways the architects never
could have foreseen, sometimes
even completely subverting the
original intent.
He uses the classic marshmallow
test, that psychological parable
about delayed gratification, to
brilliantly illustrate this
difference in sort of temporal
logic, the conceptual vanguard
who've often spent years devoted
to these long term deferred
outcomes.
They design these elaborate
systems that demand patience,
incremental progress.
Right.
But the recipients, often
they've experienced a lifetime
of systemic neglect, maybe
broken promises.
So they operate on a completely
different logic.
It's about immediate survival.
They might eat the marshmallow
before the test even starts.
Or, as the author puts it quite
starkly, they might find the
whole bag or even eat the
experimenter.
Wow.
And he stresses, this isn't a
deficiency on their part.
It's just a different way of
existing, of surviving in a
world that hasn't really offered
them much predictability or
security for the future.
And this fascinating disconnect,
this gap between the Vanguard's
long term planning and the
recipient's immediate survival
needs plays out, Abraham argues,
not just in psych experiments
but in real world social
initiatives.
You see it really clearly, he
contends, in these well meaning
attempts to, say, fill food
deserts or bring some kind of
corporate mercy into neglected
neighborhoods.
It's almost mythological how
often it repeats, right?
Elite policy grads write white
papers, socially conscious
corporations open a big flagship
store.
And then, maybe within a decade,
the whole experiment retreats.
And the stated reasons are
always framed very delicately.
You hear things like
unsustainable margins or
security concerns, maybe
community misalignment, but the
quiet truth, as the author puts
it, is that the Organism just
rejected the transplant.
What actually survives in these
places?
It isn't the Whole Foods or the
big branded chain stores that
were supposed to arrive.
OK, so this is where it gets
really interesting.
What does survive?
Yeah.
According to him, well, the
Korean groceries, the fortified
bodegas, the Chinese take out
places with those thick lexan
windows, these aren't monuments
to some grand utopian vision,
Not at all.
They're adaptable.
They're defensive architectures,
and they thrive not because of
some top down plan or systemic
alignment.
They thrive because they evolved
to survive distrust, theft,
economic pressure, even the
necessary moral ambiguities, as
he puts it, of serving a
community that often operates by
different rules than the one set
by the vanguard.
He calls them commercial Gray
Man, invisible, unflashy, but
incredibly resilient.
Exactly.
And this leads us straight into
Abraham's broader Gray man
archetype.
He suggests this is an archetype
he knows personally, having
survive some challenging
situations himself, not through
dominance, but through
calculated invisibility, by de
escalating threats, and even
quite provocatively, by
sometimes weaponizing the
performance of cowardice.
Performing cowardice?
How does that work?
Well, the idea is that appearing
weak or deferential can actually
be camouflage for immense latent
capability.
It's like his analogy of hiding
a bear in a windbreaker.
You think you're dealing with
something harmless, but
underneath there's this powerful
force just waiting.
OK, I see.
And this is where Abraham takes
that Gray man concept into some
really provocative territory.
Applying at the political
strategy, he asserts that
regardless of its narrative
flaws, one political side, the
right, has actually been
training this Gray man class, as
he calls it, in silence and long
term strategy for quite some
time now.
His argument is that while the
left might have been more
focused on, say, symbolic
protest and spectacle, the right
was quietly graduating
generations of operatives,
operatives coming out of
leadership institutes that
specialize not in street theater
but in things like appellate
law, regulatory chess, the
really long game of what Abraham
calls cultural terraforming.
Terraforming.
Yeah, essentially slowly,
deliberately reshaping the
fundamental landscape of
societal beliefs and norms over
time.
So if we connect this to the
bigger picture, think about the
example Abraham uses, Roe V
Wade, he points out.
It wasn't undone in the streets
through massive protests, right?
It was undone, he argues, in the
filing cabinets of forgotten
NGOs and legal foundations,
where yesterday's interns are
now today's judges.
The Gray men, in this view, won
that particular long game, and
Abraham observes, kind of
chillingly, no one even noticed,
which really challenges that
common idea.
That impact has to be loud and
visible, doesn't it?
It really does.
And in its stark contrast, he
argues, the left's vanguard
often insists on spectacle, on
being seen.
And spectacle, he warns, well,
it's like shouting at a
crocodile.
It just draws heat.
Every generation, he suggests,
has its stage moms of ideology.
It's showrunners of justice
directors who just can't resist
putting themselves in the
credits.
But then you have to ask, what's
the cost of being in that
spotlight?
Like in the film Wag the Dog,
the author notes it's often the
one who seeks the credit who
ultimately gets, well,
eliminated.
The lesson, he says, is ancient.
Stay small.
Do your work disappear?
He then offers another metaphor,
maybe even better than the
marshmallow test or wag the dog,
the airlock, the conceptual
Vanguard.
They believe they're entering
the ship right, participating in
the mission, contributing to the
great experiment.
But they're actually still in
the transition chamber, being
monitored, pressure tested,
filtered.
Very few, he suggests, ever
actually make it onto the ship
proper.
Many are just left suspended
indefinitely in this sort of
sealed waiting room filled with
narratives about progress.
So the wisest course, Abraham
seems to imply, might not be to
bang on that airlock door,
demanding access or recognition.
Instead, maybe it's about
studying the structure itself,
learning its rhythms, figuring
out ways to breathe within it.
Because for all the high theory
and performative justice we see
today, the quiet truth might
still be that survival and real
profound change often belong to
those who are under estimated
just long enough to actually
finish their work, often
completely out of sight.
So what does this all mean for
you?
Listening, We've explored this
really powerful idea that true
survival deep impact.
It often belongs not to the
loud, credit seeking vanguard,
but to these Gray men, those who
work silently, adapt
defensively, and crucially,
finish their work while being
underestimated.
It really makes you wonder,
doesn't it?
What other invisible successes
are we overlooking just because
they don't fit our grand
narratives?
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, it raises a
really important question, I
think.
In a world that seems obsessed
with spectacle, with immediate
recognition, what if the most
profound changes are actually
happening just out of sight?
What if the real broadsword, as
he puts it, the one that cleaves
the world in 2, is the one you
never see swung?
It's a.
Powerful lesson, Almost an
ancient 1, isn't it?
Stay small, do your work,
disappear.
And as the author reminds us,
echoing those themes from Wag
the Dog, the director who
demands applause rarely gets to
see the credits roll.
So for you, we'll leave you with
this to Mull over.
Maybe consider the value of
quiet persistence, of strategic
invisibility in your own
endeavors, whatever they might
be.
What work could you potentially
accomplish if you weren't so
concerned with getting the
credit or the fanfare?
Thank you for joining us on this
deep dive.
Until next time, keep thinking,
keep questioning, and maybe,
just maybe, try being a little
more like that Baron, a
windbreaker.